Thanks to KiwiCo for supporting this
episode of Journey to the Microcosmos!
Click the link in the description to
learn more and for a special offer.
The paramecium is the consummate model organism.
It’s a protozoan that is both easy to grow
and easy to study, which means that
microbiologists have been able to learn
all sorts of secrets about eukaryotic life
by watching them. You might even call the
paramecium a hero in our pursuit of knowledge.
But just as heroes in stories have enemies,
the paramecium has its own foe. And it
is this strange critter. No, not the big
eggplant-shaped looking thing. The smaller one,
the one that looks a bit like a swimming okra.
This is didinium, though it wasn’t always called
that. When Otto Friedrich Müller first described
it in 1786, he thought he was observing a
Vorticella, and so he named it Vorticella nasuta.
Almost a century later, Samuel Friedrich
Stein would change its name to Didinium.
Like its paramecium foil, the didinium is a
ciliate. But at first glance, it doesn’t seem
like it should be much of a problem. For
one thing, paramecium can just get so much
larger than a didinium.
Plus, the didinium is
just weird-looking. In fact, between the
paramecium and the didinium, the didinium is
the one that actually looks like food. We compared
it to an okra earlier, but at other times it looks
more like a stretched out acorn. And the pointier
bit looks like a jalapeño stem. Of course,
it is not a stem, it is the didinium’s proboscis,
which means that is the front of the organism.
And there’s still plenty of weird to go.
The didinium has a long macronucleus that
curves into a sort of figure eight shape.
And circling the organism’s body are two
rows of cilia called pectinelles
that seem almost randomly placed.
One row sits at the border of the
proboscis and the rest of the body,
while the other clinches the middle like a
loose belt. It’s a little bit tough to see
the pectinelles in their full fringy glory with
our microscope—they look more like 4 bundles of
hair on the sides of the didinium. But you can see
what it looks like better in this illustration.
And those cilia give didinium both its
very fast and very strange movement.
When the didinium moves, it really moves—but
not necessarily in a way that seems obvious
to us at first glance. Just trying to follow
it with a camera feels a little stressful.
The first time James found one, it slipped
so quickly in and out of view that he barely
caught a glimpse. He had to switch to a lower
magnification so he could zoom out and see it.
But for the didinium, this seemingly
out-of-control movement is very deliberate. It’s
constantly rotating in a clockwise fashion, but
also leaning towards one side so that it’s moving
in a spiral path. In the early 20th century,
scientists added ink to jelly just so they
could slow the didinium down and follow this path.
The microbe’s seemingly aimless trajectory helps
the didinium cover a wide range space in a
short amount of time. Think of it compared
to another skilled hunter we watched recently, the
lacrymaria olor, which sends its neck out into all
directions to maximize the odds of encountering
something. The didinium is doing something similar
but instead of extending its neck, it’s sending
its whole body into different directions.
And that speed is a big reason why didinium is
so effective. As it zips around the microcosmos,
it will bump into things that don’t
happen to be food. And when it does,
it politely backs up and moves on.
But if its proboscis makes contact with something
edible, then the didinium goes to work seizing
its prey with its proboscis, paralyzing it, and
then eating it. And while it is known to consume
other organisms, what didinium really really
likes to eat are paramecium. It doesn’t matter
that a paramecium might be six times its size,
the didinium is here for a meal and it will gladly
expand itself around the paramecium to swallow it.
But as you can see, this is not a smooth process.
The didinium is still moving and bumping around as
it consumes the paramecium, and for a while, it’s
hard to even tell where predator ends and the prey
begins. The only real didinium-like thing about
it is the spiral path it still takes as it eats
and eats and eats. But eventually it settles
back into its more awkward-looking self.
So incredible is the didinium’s appetite
that scientists have observed it eating
a pair of dividing paramecium. They’ve
also occasionally been observed
exploding from eating too much. So
there are hazards to this lifestyle.
But while the didinium is extremely talented at
hunting paramecium, and also capable of hunting
other organisms, it’s actually pretty bad in some
of its other conquests. When didinium try to eat
rotifers, they’re stymied by the relatively tough
exterior. And other ciliates like stentors are
too large and too tough and too active
for the didinium to do much damage to.
And paired with its favorite prey, the didinium is
its own model system. In the early 20th century,
mathematicians came up with equations to describe
how populations of predators and prey oscillate
in response to each other. More predators means
less prey, which then means fewer predators and
more prey. Lather, rinse, and repeat, and you
get a cycle that shapes relationships between
species in many different environments.
And in attempting to see if they could
re-create these equations that were for the
macroscopic world in a microscopic environment,
scientists in labs turned to paramecium and
didinium to act as a model predator-prey system.
It turned out to be not so straightforward
to mimic nature in the lab.
When scientists first started watching didinium
and paramecium in a flask, the didinium would
inevitably consume the paramecium to extinction,
in turn driving their own deaths. It was only by
building on these experiments and finding ways to
adjust the interactions between predator and prey
that they could reconstruct the
oscillations we expect in nature.
Of course, that doesn’t mean they directly
copied what nature does. How could they
with an experimental design meant to strip
many of the confounding elements of ecology
from their observations? But their work still
provided insights into how organisms interact.
It’s like a story: incapable of holding the vast
entirety of our existence, and yet still very
useful in its narrowness. That the consummate
model organism has such a consummate model
predator then is quite fortunate for us, even
if for the microcosmos, it’s just another story.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to KiwiCo
for supporting this episode.
KiwiCo creates super cool hands-on projects
for kids that make learning fun! With a KiwiCo
subscription, each month the kid in your life
will receive a fun, engaging new project which
will help develop their creativity and confidence!
They have eight subscription lines, each catering
to different age groups and topics, and each
box is designed by experts and tested with kids.
In their Eureka Crate, intended for ages 14
and up, you can get this 2-in-1 lantern kit
that lets you construct a camping lantern
that also transforms into a flashlight.
So if you want to give a gift that keeps
the fun and learning going all year long,
a KiwiCo subscription delivers STEAM discovery
long after the holiday decorations are put away.
So head on over to kiwico.com/journey50
and use the code “journey50” or click
the link in the description for 50%
off your first month of ANY crate!
And thank you, as always, to our patrons, all of
the people on the screen right now. You’re the
people that keep this show happening. If you want
to become one of those people and support this
show, you can go to Patreon.com/journeytomicro
If you want to see more from our Master
of Microscopes James, check
out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.